[Music]
hallo YouTube just love us in my friends
this is guns in here welcome to my fifth
episode of love and colossal interprete
from the black respect to you in this
episode we are going to look at the moon
eight Queen to d2 which arises after the
following model ephone C Phi Knight to
f3 Knight to c6 d4 C captures d4 Knight
captures d4 d5 Knight to be v eh6 Knight
to d6 Czech Bishop captures d6 Queen
captures d6 Queen to f6 attacking the
Queen and now Queen to d2 as per the
database there are roughly 500 free day
games played with this moon and against
this s
I have highlighted over here black has
two popular choices amongst them I am
NOT going to concentrate on the move
Queen to g6 the simple reason is after
the move f3 not only White Queen can
protect the g2 but white light squared
Bishop can be liberated and some of the
position arises from this variation are
not that great for the black camp so my
suggestion is you should completely
avoid this and played our universal move
at this position namely Knight G to e7
so we are looking at this thematic break
defy and that's why 90% of the game
continued with Knight to c3 which is in
fact the main line from this position
however there are few games continue
with C fool with not so great result for
the white camp as it simply allowed the
Moon Knight to deform and I have
attached a model game in the PGN which
will give you a very good idea how to
play against the move c4 Knight to c3
what else
and after this move here comes the first
memory marker guys just remember the
simple plan of campaign by black camp
what black wants to do is he wants to
play d6 followed by Castle and Bishop to
e6 and this two rooks are going to come
to d8 and see it and then at the right
time black is going to play the Moody
file with a very good initiative so this
is more or less of a trademark plan if
white does not play actively and
continue with some passing moves you
should also note that Queen to d2 also
Jam up the Queen side so it is not easy
for white to quickly go into the
queenside castle and that give us ample
time to activate all our pieces so now
let's see some of the critical responses
by wide and how we can handle it d6
first of your small and as per the
theory the main move in this position is
b3 trying to free up the dark screw
Bishop and quickly goes on to the
queenside castle however White has
frequently tried other moves and let's
see each part on the first move I want
to consider is Bishop to c4 which is
very obvious controlling the d4 square
but however after the move Bishop to e6
black actually achieve what he wants to
do if Bishop to b3 then Knight to d4 is
a very strong reply and again white
doesn't want to capture this mission the
simple reason is after Queen captures a6
castle on the Kings side black has a
very simple plan to execute namely
castle and then quick afire which gives
him a very good position so accordingly
the best move in this position is Knight
to d5
however we know from our past video that
when
ever the night appears on the d5 square
we are going to chop it off and again
why it has to be careful how he is going
to recapture this piece for example
white can already go wrong if he
continued with Bishop captures defy
hands after the move Queen to g6 I think
white is in a big trouble he cannot even
play g3 the simple reason is after the
move Knight to d4 there are two threats
are looming and white cannot bury both
of them of course white needs to save
the queen and whenever the Queen moves
let's say Queen to d3 we have this
simple move Knight captures d5 pawn
captures defy Queen captures Queen pawn
takes and night to see to check Vince
the game on the spot
you
there is one game in the database which
continue with castle on the kingside
which is again a dubious me and the
simple refutation is yup this trademark
move Knight to d4 looking at that juicy
folk Quinn to Devin getting out of the
folk but what white muslin is after
Knight captures d5 pawn captures defy
and the move Knight capture c2 White has
completely hopeless position
just one move rook to b1 and black
deliver this ultimate blow boom white
reside
you
so it is pretty clear that here white
has to capture with the epon and after
that my recommendation is you should
continue with Quint which for attacking
the bishop now taking the c6 Knight is a
pretty bad idea for white camp the
simple reason is after pawn capture c6
queen capture c4 pawn captures b7 we
have Queen to e4 check which not only
regained the pawn but after Castle and
black castles you can see the pressure
is mounting on b2 which is making hard
to develop this dark square bishop and
on top black has this wonderful center
and later on he can push forward with D
5 D for all in all I think this position
is quite better for the black camp
instead of capturing on c6 what happens
if white continue with Bishop to b3 well
that is the case between two 2100 rated
opponent where white obviously continued
with Bishop to b3 after that black
continue with this annoying me quint we
forecheck hitting on g2 so white
responses force white has to play King
to have fun and now comes Knight to d4
okay why try to annoy black with f3 but
it doesn't matter as after Queen to a5
King to f2 so giving a space to the roof
to come on D or the e-file well no
matter black just castle on the Kings
side and after the move c3 obviously
black chopped up this - a pair context
b3 and now comes look to see it grabbing
the typical open Sicilian C file
white continue it rook to d1 and after
the move rook to c5 as you can see from
the rating white was low rated I think
he was playing for the draw with this
move Queen to Jafar White's
idea is after Queen takes Bishop takes
AB six Bishop to h4 rook captures defy
rook captures d5 Knight captures defy he
was to get his pawn back with rook to d1
and yes indeed if somehow if white can
reach the equality there are chances of
getting draw from this position but
unfortunately what white missed days
after the Moon Knight to e7
suddenly he cannot take the d6 pawn as
after the move Knight to a5 he is going
to lose a piece
well in the game he tried the Mooji
phone stopping Knight to a5 but now it's
too late
as after GFI attacking the bishop bishop
to g3 and the MU defy black consolidated
his extra pawn and later on indeed
managed to win the game you can check
rest of the game in the PG n which will
give you a very good idea how easily
black converted his advantage
the second move I want to consider his
Queen to g5 which personally I don't
like he and the refutation goes as
follows black has this amazing counter
resource night two before attacking the
weak seat upon after Queen takes and
pawn takes Bishop to d3 then black can
continue with rook to g8 and later on
any time black can take this bishop and
get a good position so accordingly the
best response here is King to Devin
defending on the C to pawn
well if this is the best continuation in
Queen to defy Lyon then we should more
than happy to play against this
variation I'm just giving you a sample
line which will highlight how easy black
position is
black should continue with Bishop to b6
controlling the d5 square and after the
moon a3 we can happily retrieve a knight
back to c6
the plan you have to remember is no
matter here
whatever white plays let's say Bishop to
e3 we are going to get rid of our double
pawn with fi and then quickly followed
by castle on the Queen side which not
only gives black a tremendous center but
black all pieces are very active and
white is literally struggling for the
activity
you
so considering all these factors I think
b3 is reasonably the main line at
disjunction
okay we are going to castle on the Kings
side and now White has two choices
white can play Bishop to a3 which
threatened the d6 pawn but in fact it is
just an illusion and black and literally
ignore it and continue with Bishop to e6
now let's see what happens if white
capture on d6 the first move I want to
consider ace Queen captures d6 which is
not a good capture as rook to d8 come
with a tempo and after the move Queen to
c5 black get tremendous initiative with
Knight to d4 attacking on weak seat upon
here it doesn't matter whether white
continue with castle or Bishop to d3
let's say in one of the game white
continue with castle on the Kings side
black played obviously Queen captures f2
threatening a checkmate and regaining
the pawn back and after the move Bishop
to d3 black just save his Knight with
Knight to g6 rook to f1 happen on the
board but as there is no threats are
looming black is more than happy to chop
the pawns with Queen captures g2 white
become now desperate and he tried to
attack the Queen all the time with rook
to g1 Queen captures s true rook to h1
Quinn to f2 rook to have fun so we have
some cat-and-mouse going on with rooks
are following the Queen but after Queen
check came to be one just one moon and
white can resign
well before I move on I like you to
pause this video and find out a decisive
blow by black which literally kills the
white
did you find it
let's see the star mo is P six and White
Queen is running out of the square if
green to see seven then look to see it
is very strong reply and in the game
white indeed play Queen captures b6
which in fact one of the best reply as
per the engine but after the decisive
Moon Knight captures f2 white lose the
game on the spot
the simple reason is after Queen takes
and Knight takes black is attacking to
sports and white cannot defend both of
them
ok let's check out what happens after
Bishop captures d6 well more or less we
have the same response rook a to d8
Bishop captures a 7 attacking the Queen
Queen captures a 7
and after the obvious move Bishop to d3
black has this nice moon night before
so blacks idea is very simple he wants
to create a backward d3 pawn which he
can take it later part in the middle
game white can choose either side castle
but the scenario will not change for
example I have reached this position in
one of the rapid game where my opponent
continued with castle on the Kings side
I responded with rook to d7 so planning
is very simple I want to double up and
then take my pawn back my opponent plays
Knight to d1 so his idea is very nice
that if I continue with rook to d8 then
he wants to play Knight to be P and then
consolidate his Bishop matter black
played energetically with f5 attacking
on e4 wide defended with f3 and after F
captures e 4f captures e4 black has this
sneaky check Queen to c5 which I think
decide the game on the spot
white cannot block the check with either
of the piece so in the game he decided
to continue with Quinn to e3 but this
again doesn't turn out well as after
Queen takes Knight takes Knight captures
d3 white remove the one pair of rook
with rook captures f8 King kept as f8
and now pawn captures d3 but see the
difference now not only black get his
pawn back with attacking the knight but
once white played the moon think we have
to the rook is posted on the second rank
and after King to f3 and the move b5
yes in terms of material we have
equality but in terms of replacement
black literally on the white
so it is very obvious that taking the d6
pawn is a risky way to play for the
white can so that is why the most
accurate response here is to castle on
the Queen side and after that we are
going to continue with our automatic
plan yup
rook to c8 planning to go rook to DA and
then defy
well again taking on d6 while your queen
is sitting on d2 is a risky way to play
so in one game
white continued with Quinn to e3 and now
indeed he is threatening to capture on
d6 what amazed me about this vision is
still black and go the MOOC to d8 and
white still cannot take the pawn why
let's see what happens after Bishop
captures v6 well again there are some
tactical problems start with Knight to
d4 if Bishop drops back to a 3 then B
Phi is a very strong reply and black
initiative rundown on the Queen side so
in the game why try the move Bishop
captures a 7 and after Queen captures a
7 he stopped the Queen check with King
2b to same time defending the c3 Knight
so at first sight it looks like White
has consolidated his extra pawn right
well guess what after blacks next few
replies rook to c6 Bishop to d3 and rook
to c8 suddenly white geared up
completely losing position his Knight
get attacked and in the game he played
the Moon Knight to e2 which is a big
time disaster as there is a forcing made
happens after this moon and I hope you
see it right yup it start with rook cap
to see to check bishop capture c2 rook
to c2 check King to b1 and now the star
moon Queen to e3 and white cannot stop
put the chocolates
so finally let's see the main line move
with Bishop to b2 our response is very
obvious Bishop to b6 and now White has
three choices
number one Queen captures b6 at this
position is a big time disaster as after
rook to d8 Queen to c5 and now Knight to
d4 again the same sequence give I a
great headache
he cannot even castle at this time the
simple reason is after Queen captures f2
Bishop to d3 this time around Bishop is
sitting on b2 which gives black this
winning option Knight captures b3 and
White Queen is a simply corner
the second option castle is not good
either the simple reason is we can
continue with our automatic baton rook a
to see each and if you take on d6 then I
will take on f2
so accordingly one of the high-level
game in the database continued with King
to be one which I think already an
inaccurate as it allowed our thematic
break
Tifa yup
the point is after pawn takes Knight
takes Knight takes and Bishop takes
our Bishop is wonderfully eyeing it G 2
squared and in the next move we are
going to continue it rook to d8 with a
very active game and if white thinks
that he can win the peace with Queen
captures d5
well this is the last time he is going
to play this as after the accurate
response rooks say to d8 white got a
completely losing position
you
last but not least what happens if white
continued with Knight to d5
well I think this is the only variation
where we are not going to capture this
night the simple reason is our scene ID
doesn't have any good squares to go so
my recognition here is remember this
second important memory marker Queen to
h4 attacking the wheat eforp all
and this is actually happen between
Peter Laco and Vallejo ponds a very
high-level game where Laco continued
eight nightcap to z7 night captures a
seven and now the moon Bishop to d3
defending the e4 pawn well frankly
speaking whenever the Bishop d3 happen
we know what to do
yup our traumatic break defy and black
is already looking quite better from
this position if he kept us Levi then
Bishop captures D fire is a very strong
reply and the important point you need
to know is after Bishop kept his ePHI
which looks like white is winning a pawn
but in fact it's not as after D captures
evil black is in a completely travel
seat if Bishop moves then rook to d8 is
a very strong reply and technically we
are holding on to have a pawn for
example if white continue with g3 then
we have Queen to h5 and white is going
to lose a piece so that's not a good
choice and you might ask what about
Bishop to d3 well same story as we are
going to continue with Queen to f6 and
again white is going to lose a piece
so considering all these options white
continue with Quinn - III but that
allows to expand on Quinn side faith
defo after Quinn - G 3 Queen takes pawn
takes and the move Knight to c6 yes
indeed White has a bishop pair but look
at the position it is completely block
and that is why black has slight
advantage in this position well why try
to open up the position with C 3 but
doesn't matter black played rook F to D
and after king - e - here comes the
winning move of the game AFI and you can
see the simple idea black wants to play
a4 and then target the weak a - pawn
which surprisingly enough white cannot
do anything about it
well he tried seek up to Steve food
night kept his D for Chad and after king
- III black indeed pushed the pawn to e4
square after F 4 and F 6 vite fine
nothing better than capture on e4 but
that simply activates the black roofs
with rook captures a fool and if a 3
then B fire is a very strong reply white
position already becomes best friend and
he tried the moon Luke edge to see one
grabbing the C file and I think black
made an inaccurate move with rook
captures a tune which allow white to
come back in the game and in fact the
game has been drawn but I can show you
the improvement and black should
continue at this position with b5 the
point is after pawn takes pawn takes
rook to c5 black has this dynamic
resource Bishop to a5 not only getting
rid of the bishop an but see the
activity and pressure black and generate
from this position a sample line can
draw like this Bishop takes pawn takes
so now indeed White has to move the rook
has night - C - folk is in the air and
it doesn't matter wherever this rook
moves let's say look to c1 we can
continue with rook a to say to attacking
the bishop that poor bishop cannot move
has after let's say Bishop to c3 black
can simply check me to my king
the best white can do over here is
Bishop kept his D phone but after pawn
takes King to f3 rook check King to e2
rook to e3 check King to f2 rook to
effect check came to Jeevan and now the
winning me
d3 and it turns out that after whole
this sequence not only black emerge with
an extra pawn but those two passers can
finish up the game very quickly
why cannot even touch on seafood the
simple reason is after d2 rook to d1 and
the move rook to d1 check black is
deciding the game on the spot
you
well that's it guys with this broad
coverage I think you are now confident
enough to meet the move Queen to d2
remember this simple and effective plan
of campaign by black so almost against
all the white variation we want to play
d6 castle and Bishop to e6 and put our
rook on D and C file which gives black a
very comfortable and acting King well
thank you for watching this video feel
free to like subscribe and comment and
I'll meet you in my next episode very
soon bye and take care
you